Ja, ich werde mit Ihnen das Erstgespräch führen.
Zunächst stelle ich Ihnen einige Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten.
Danach besprechen wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden.
Wie heißen Sie?
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Frau Sabine Müller.
Frau Sabine Müller.
Frau Müller, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ich bin etwas heiser, deswegen kann ich nicht so gut sprechen.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Ich versuche mein Bestes.
Okay, ich kann vielleicht Ihnen helfen.
Wenn ich mich falsch gesagt habe, könnten Sie mir bitte korrigieren.
Sabine mit S-A-B-I-N-A.
Nach dem Bertha Ida Nordpol-E-Mid.
Sabine.
Sabine, okay, mit E, alles klar.
Und Nachname?
Noch mal bitte.
Müller.
Müller mit 2 L?
Mit 2 L, einem E und einem R.
Okay, alles klar.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23.11.1900.
Katja, ja, 1900.
Egal.
Alles klar.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Oh, zu viel, einfach zu viel.
76 kg.
Ich habe über Weihnachten noch mal etwas zugenommen.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Es gibt viele Kekse und so weiter.
Ja, genau.
76 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,75 m.
Alles klar.
Frau Müller, wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist die Frau
Brasius.
Genau, Brasius.
Okay, danke schön.
Frau Müller, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Sie hören, meine Stimme ist ganz heiser.
Genau.
Ich habe Halsschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen
und starken Husten.
Und es ist sehr trocken alles.
Okay, Kopfschmerzen auch, oder?
Ja, Kopfschmerzen.
Ich bin sehr müde und schlapp.
Ich kann kaum schlucken.
Ich versuche etwas zu trinken.
Dann habe ich Halsweh.
Es brennt richtig im Hals.
Ich bekomme ganz schlecht Luft.
Meine Nase ist zu.
Ich muss immer wieder husten.
Ich habe immer wieder husten.
Ja, genau, zurück in den Husten.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit 4 Tagen, ungefähr.
Es wird immer schlimmer.
Seit gestern habe ich auch Fieber.
39 Grad.
Ist diese Fieber dauerhaft?
Ich nehme dann Paracetamol.
Ich nehme dann wieder Paracetamol.
Dann kommt es wieder.
Wie viele Dosierungen kennen Sie?
Paracetamol?
Ich nehme das 3-4 Mal am Tag.
3-4 Mal am Tag.
Nach der Einnahme von Medikamenten
geht es wieder besser.
Ein wenig.
Das Fieber fällt etwas ab.
Auf 37, 8.
Aber danach steigt es wieder an.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie
oder freundliche Umgebung
ähnliche Beschwerden?
Meine Nachbarn sind krank geworden.
Unser Kind im Kindergarten
war vor einer Zeit schon seit über 1,5 Stunden.
Er war vor einer Zeit schon seit 1,5 Stunden.
Er war vor einer Woche krank.
Jetzt fängt auch mein Mann an.
Gibt es bestimmte Diagnose bei Ihnen?
Wir waren beim Kinderarzt.
Er meinte, das ist ein Virusinfekt.
Aber sonst hat er nichts gemacht.
Sie haben mir gesagt,
dass Sie auch Husten haben.
Zuerst einen Husten oder keinen Auswurf?
Kaum, ganz wenig.
Es ist eher sehr trocken.
Gibt es keine Blutungen?
Beim Auswurf im Reich?
Nein.
Ist ja kein Blutrein.
Alle Beschwerden
sind bestehend.
Das ist ein Problem.
Wie fängt diese Beschwerden?
Ich habe sie schon seit 4 Tagen bestehend.
Wie hat diese Beschwerden?
Ich habe sie relativ schnell und kurzfristig angefangen.
Ich war schwer krank.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie gegen diese Beschwerden
nur Paracetamol eingenommen?
Ja, ich mag keine Tabletten.
Ich habe nur Paracetamol eingenommen.
Dann habe ich verschiedene Hausmittel probiert.
Frischer Zitrone, Thymian,
und
Pferoments, Inhalationen,
Nasenspray.
Meiner See, EZ
oder medikamente,
pflanzliche Medikamente.
Ja, pflanzlich, überwiegend pflanzlich.
Ja, okay.
Frau Müller, haben Sie mit mir gesagt,
dass Sie auch Kopfschmerzen haben?
Ja, sehr schön.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Wo genau?
Und wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala,
wiebliward?
Das ist meistens am Seiten, am Augen.
Beide, aber vorhin.
Genau, dann habe ich das Gefühl,
mein Kopf wird etwas eingeengt.
Okay.
Wie dumpfer sind die?
Ja, das sind eher dumpfer Schmerzen.
Das stimmt.
Frau Müller auf einer Schmerzskala. Also seit gestern ist schon sehr stark, würde sagen so 5 bis 6 bei
einer Skala von 10. 5 bis 6 von 10, okay. Leitern Sie unter auch Nackensteifigkeit, bemerken Sie das?
Was meinen Sie mit Nackensteifigkeit? Also mein Nacken und rücken ist schon sehr
verspannt. Verspannt aber ja, wenn Sie ihr Nacken vorne beugen, fühlen Sie ganze Rücken
der Schmerzen. Ja, ich kann nach vorne beugen, das geht ja. Das geht kein Problem.
Okay, sehr gut. Leitern Sie unter Übelkeit? Nein. Nein, okay. Oder Erbrechen? Keine.
Nein. Nein. Okay, alles klar. Ja, Frau Müller, jetzt besprechen wir ein bisschen Ihre aktuelle
medizinische Zustand. Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie seit vier Tagen auch hohe Sieber,
ungefähr 39 Grad, leiten Sie unter Stilfrost und Nachtschweiß? Nein. Also jetzt seit vier
Tagen muss ich schon auch viel schwitzen, wenn ich Fieber habe. Ansonsten, wenn Sie jetzt meinen,
ob ich das immer habe, nein, das ist jetzt nun im Rahmen dieses Infektes. Okay. Und haben Sie
Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang? Nein. Nein. Nein. Gut. Wie ist Ihr Schlaf,
Frau Müller? Im Moment verschlägt, werde durch den Husten immer sehr schnell wach. Und da kann
ich auch schlecht einschlafen. Ich bekomme schnellen Luft. Und das ist sehr schwierig im Moment.
Ja, okay. Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Atmenut beschreiben beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen,
die können Sie beschreiben? Schwierig für mich war bei beiden. Also ich, die Nase ist zu und
durch die Halsschmerzen bekomme ich schlecht Luft. Und dann muss ich auch immer Husten und dann ist
auch das Ausatmen etwas schwierig. Okay. Okay. Haben Sie normalerweise Husten beschwerten?
Normalerweise nicht. Nein. Normalerweise nicht, oder? Okay. Das ist neu. Okay. Frau Müller hat
sich Ihr Appetit und Gewicht in letzter Zeit verändert? Nein. Nein. Bis auch über Weihnachten
habe ich etwas zugenommen, aber. Okay. Okay. Aber gewollte Kiru oder? Nein. Ja. Gut. Ja. Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstolpe? Nein. Nein. Okay. Okay. Frau Müller, wann war Ihre
letzte Periode? Sind Ihre Periode regelmäßig? Ist Ihre Periode? Ja, ja. Also da gibt es keine
Probleme. Nein. Keine Probleme. Okay. Trainieren Sie normalerweise regelmäßig? Trainieren, was
meinen Sie? Sport. Machen Sie Sport? Nein. Nein. Da bin ich zufahrene. Nein. Okay. Okay.
Alles klar. Ich sollte eigentlich aber. Nein. Okay. Nun hätte ich einige Fragen zu
Genussmitzeln, Frau Müller. Rauchen Sie? Nein. Nein. Okay. Haben Sie früher geraucht? Nein. Nein.
Nur eine Feier oder wenn man mit Freunden mal weg war, aber ich normalerweise rauche ich nicht.
Okay. Okay. Prima. Trinken Sie Alkohol? Sehr, sehr selten. Sehr selten. Ja. Was
meinen Sie damit zum Beispiel einmal? Ein Geburtstagsfeier oder? Okay. Und was trinken Sie gerne?
Ja, Wein. Kernes und Wein. Wein. Ja. Okay. Wie viel Glas trinken Sie in diesem Moment?
Nicht viel. Ein oder zwei Gläsern. Okay. Ja, Frau Müller, nehmen Sie Droge? Nein. Nein. Okay.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeiten? Nein. Ist mir ein bisschen nicht bekannt. Nein.
Leiden Sie an einer chronischen Erkrankung? Nicht Erkrankung?
Chronisch, was meinen Sie damit? Wie zum Beispiel Bruthoffdruck, Schilddröse, Unterhüperfektion.
Ach so, nein. Nein. Okay. Oder Migräne kann sein, Astem und Astra. Nein.
Okay. Alles klar. Gut. Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert? Ja. Vor sechs Jahren wurde ich an der
Gallenblase operiert. Okay. Da hatte ich so ein bisschen Schmerzen gehabt. Und dann hieß es,
dass ich Gallenblase in Steine habe und es muss operiert werden. Okay. Vor sechs Jahren.
Okay. Gibt es noch andere Operationen? Nein, bisher nicht. Nein. Okay. Prima. War diese
Operation komplikationslos? War alles okay. Das war nur zwei Tage im Krankenhaus und das war
völlig unentnottene. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig irgendwelche Medikamente ein? Nein. Nur wenn ich
mal Schmerzen habe, nehme ich Ibuprofen, aber ansonsten nicht. Nein. Ja, okay. Und dieses Mal
nehmen Sie Pracetamol ein, aber sonst eine. Nein, sonst nicht genau. Okay. Bei Bedarf können
wir sagen. Okay. Frau Nuda, gibt es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche Krunschenerkrankungen? In Ihrer
Familie ist ja gut meine Mutter, die hat eine Schilddrüse, Problematik und nimmt deswegen
Medikamente, aber ich weiß nicht, was. Okay. Ich weiß es nicht. Also in einem Schilddrösen
Tabletten. Okay. Und mein Vater hat Bluthohenblutdruck. Da nimmt er Blutdrucktabletten und ich und
ich meine, er hat auch irgendwas mit Cholesterin, aber ich weiß es nicht. Okay. Okay. Sie kennen
nur Blutdruckdruck, dann? Ja, genau. Aber wie viele Pracetamol Medikamente sind, weiß ich
leider nicht. Okay, okay. Frau Müller, was sind Sie von Beruf? Ich bin Diplom-Ingenieurin und arbeite
in einer Firma. Diplom-Ingenieurin. Ja. Was machen Sie genau? Ich betreue ein Projekt,
das heißt wir machen Pläne für große Maschinen, für Schiffe. Wie ist Ihre Wohnsituation,
Frau Müller? Wohnsituation, was meinen Sie? Ja, leben Sie allein oder? Ach so, ich bin
verheiratet und wir haben eine Tochter. Eine Tochter, okay. Wohnen Sie mit Ihrem Mann? Ja,
ja, ja. Ist Ihre Tochter gesund? Ihre Tochter gesund? Ja, glücklicherweise geht es sehr gut.
Ja. Okay. Haben Sie Geschwester, Frau Müller? Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist zwei Jahre
älter als ich, aber dem geht es auch gut. Okay, gibt es keine? Nein, nein. Ja, hat keine. Okay,
Cruncher. Ja, super. Sind Sie vorständig geimpft? Als ich meine, ja, weil mein Hausarzt hat sich den
Impfausweis vor zwei Jahren angeschaut und er meinte, es ist alles komplett. Okay, okay, prima.
Haben Sie alle in fünf Fischungen machen lassen? Ja, also alles, was bisher nötig war,
habe ich machen lassen. Und COVID-19 zum Beispiel? Das habe ich nur zweimal und dann nicht mehr.
Okay, nur zweimal, alles klar. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Reise gemacht? Nein. Nein. Also,
ich war nicht im Ausland, ich war jetzt innerhalb von Deutschland unterwegs, aber nicht im
Ausland. Okay, okay. Und jetzt möchte ich einige Fragen zu Ihren Akzellen an Amnesien
nochmal besprechen. Haben Sie einen Moment? Ja, haben Sie Geschmackverlust? Geschmackverlust?
Gut, ich habe jetzt ein bisschen weniger Appetit in den letzten paar Tagen,
aber Geschmack oder Geruch ist noch nicht verloren. Nein, das hatte ich mal vor vier Jahren,
als ich mal eine Corona-Infektion hatte, jetzt aber nicht. Okay. Und ja, haben Sie Gelenkschmerzen?
Ja, jetzt Kopfschmerzen, Gelenkschmerzen, ja. Total ganzen Körper. Ja, ganz Muskeln tun auch
wie. Aber Sie haben keine Rötungen oder Schwellungen im Gedicht? Nein. Okay. Ja, Frau Müller,
ich muss das nochmal gucken. Ja, haben aber viele Fragen gestellt, Mensch. Ja, Sie haben
Reden. Ich kann schon gar nicht mehr reden, wie sind Sie, mein Hals tut jetzt noch. Ich glaube,
ich muss jetzt mal eine kleine Pause einlegen, Frau Doktor. Ja, okay, ja. Ich verstehe sehr,
dass das für Sie sehr unangenehm ist. Ich weiß, aber für Ihre Sicherheit und genaue Diagnose zu
stellen zu können, sollte ich alle diese Fragen Ihnen stellen, Frau Müller? Ja, ich verstehe das.
Kann ich mich irgendwo hinlegen? Mir wird so ein bisschen schwindlig. Ja, ja,
natürlich, ja natürlich. Bitte legen Sie sich hier. Dankeschön. Ja, ich werde Sie sofort
untersuchen und Blut abnehmen, Ihre Wettzeilparameter messen. Danach brauche ich einige operativ
diagnostische Maßnahmen. Wenn ich alle Ergebnisse zusammengetragen habe, werden wir noch einmal
miteinander sprechen. Das machen Sie alles noch heute oder? Ja, ja, ich fahre möglicherweise. Dann
machen Sie alles Hauptsache, ich werde bald wieder gesund. Vielen Dank. Ja, bitte schön. Ich komme
gleich. Vielen Dank, Frau Doktor. Sind noch Fragen von den Kollegen oder Kolleginnen?
Hallo, guten Abend. Ich habe eine Frage. Ja, bitte schön.
Haben Sie Schluckstörungen oder? Ja, habe ich zu Beginn gesagt, wenn ich etwas trinke oder
versuche, etwas zu essen, dann brennt mir das im Hals. Und in besonderer haben Sie am Hals
left not und bemerkt oder? Ich weiß es nicht. Also es tut halt alles weh im Hals.
Ja und ich habe das Gefühl, es ist sehr dick im Hals. Vielleicht ich habe,
für mich selber, ich möchte wissen und in letzter Zeit haben Sie ab oder zurückgenommen.
Vielleicht meine Kollegin hat mich gefragt, aber. Ja, Sie haben mich gefragt, aber ich habe
gesagt, außer jetzt über Weihnachten und sonst nicht. Okay, danke schön.
Sonst noch weitere Fragen, Kollegen, aber die Simulation ist sehr gut. Alle wichtige Fragen
gestärkt. Ich denke. Ja, sehr gut. Jetzt habe ich dich erkannt. Da, Doktor Montal.
Zulal ma'shallah. Ziyagute Simulation.
Danke, danke. Ma'shallah. Allahn ne der dünne Saklasin.
Äh, Abi, bu kızı şöyle.
Äh, guztak operat.
Aa, und dann meine Kollegin. Guten Tag, hallo.
Hallo.
Vielen, vielen Dank. Bei mir alles gut und Ihnen bei Ihnen.
Danke schön, danke schön, danke schön. Ich bin gespannt. Ich nehme an, Sie möchten einen Patienten vorstellen.
Genau, genau. Was haben Sie da angeschaut?
Es handelt sich um Frau Sabina Müller, eine 38-jährige Patientin.
Patientin.
Bitte. Patientin.
Patientin, Patientin. Er stellte sich heute
Sie stellte sich.
Ja, ah, schuldigung. Sie stellte sich heute
wegen seit vier Tagen bestehender Disfonie,
Sephagie, Asthenie, Odinophagie, Düsbne,
Verstopfenenase bei uns.
Ach, so viele Symptome, okay.
Bei uns vor. Ich konnte nicht hören.
So viele Symptome?
Genau, genau, sehr viele Symptome, genau.
Außerdem klagte sie über unproduktive Tussis.
Sie beschrieb seine Kopfschmerzen als Dumpf
und sie bewertet die Schmerzen ungefähr
auf einer Schmerzkala von mit fünf bis sechs von zehn.
Gegen diese Beschwerden
nehmen sie vier oder drei bis vier Mal am Tag
Paracetamol eingenommen.
Diese Medikamente hat wenig geholfen.
Außerdem hat sie Fibar seit vier Tagen ungefähr 39 Grad.
Nach Einnahme von dieser Medikament
ist Fibar 37,8 ungefähr geworden.
Es gibt in ihrer Umgebung viele ähnliche Beschwerden,
zum Beispiel ihr Tochter,
oder ihre Tochter hat eine,
ihre Tochter leidet an einer Tindavirusinfektion vor eine Woche.
Und ihre Nachbarn ist auch krank, hat ähnliche Beschwerden.
Sie haben eine Schmerzkala,
die sehr ähmetisch ist,
die Blut im Auswurf wurde verneint.
Und Geschmack und Geruch verloren wurde verneint.
Sie hat also kein Geschmacksverlust.
Genau, genau.
Und die vegetative Amamnese ist unauffällig,
bis auf Insomnia, Begendi,
Beschwerden, Fibar und Atemnur,
Dyskne, Entschuldigung, Dyskne.
Ja, und ihre Periode, Blutung ist regelmäßig.
Er, Nikotin und Rogen konsumt wurden verneint.
Sie trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol,
nur in der Ferien, nein, nur in der Feier,
wie Geburtstagfeier.
Und bei Feieralte.
Genau, Feieralte.
Ein bis zwei Gläserwein trinkt sie gerne in diesem Moment.
Bei ihr ist keine bestimmte chronische Erkrankungen bekannt.
Vor sechs Jahren wurde bei ihr eine Kolesistik-Tomy-Operation durchgeführt.
Diese Operation war komplikationslos.
Sie nimmt ab und zu gelegentlich Ibuprofen und Paracetamol-Sin ein.
Seine Mutter leidet an einer...
Ihre Mutter?
Entschuldigung.
Meine Mutter leidet an einer Thyroid-Krankheiten,
aber sie kennt diese, die Namen nicht genau.
Und ihr Vater leidet an einer alterierten Hepatonie.
Also, ja.
Sie arbeitet im Büro oder als Diplom-Ingenieur.
Ingenieur.
Ja, Ingenieur.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat eine Tochter, die gesund ist.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft.
Gegen Corona hat sie auch zweimal impfen lassen.
Und die beschwerden, wie diese dysphagie Pharyngitis und so weiter,
Mödigkeit Asthenie sprechen für einen grippalen Infekt Influenza hin.
Nein, sprechen für Influenza.
Die Pferenzialdiagnostik kommt auch...
Haben Sie einen Test gemacht, einen Schnelltest?
Nein, ich habe noch nicht gemacht.
Hat die Patientin einen Test gemacht, haben Sie sie gefragt?
Nein, ich habe das nicht gefragt.
Während der Untersuchung kann ich diese Fragen stellen.
Sie wissen ja, es gibt ja diese Schnelltests für Influenza
und andere virale Erkrankungen.
Damit kann man das relativ schnell herausfinden.
Also dann würde ich vorschlagen, dass Sie noch mal so ein Schnelltest durchschüllen.
Okay, okay.
Nicht nur gegen den Influenza, sondern auch gegen welche virale Erkrankungen
sollte man auch noch untersuchen.
Bei einem Halsschmerzen oder Pharyngitis kann es Epstein-Barm-Virus,
RSSV, RSSV, RSSV.
Was war jetzt vor ein paar Jahren sehr ausgebig?
Covid-Infektion, Corona-Infektion.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist auch wieder sehr häufig, also dagegen sollte man auch noch mal...
Genau.
Sie hat keine Geschmack- oder Geruchverlust, aber auf jeden Fall
sollten wir diese Krankheit überdenken.
Man sollte testen.
Genau.
Differenzial diagnostisch kommen diese unterschiedliche virale Infektion
und eine Bronchitis und Pneumonie in Betracht.
Um meine Vergachtstiagnose zu bestätigen,
werde ich die Patienten zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Und Blut abnehmen.
Im Blut weite ich großes Blutbild, CRP-BSG-Werte
und noch Nieren und so weiter.
Blutgase wäre vielleicht auch schlecht, Sauerstoffsetting um.
Bitte.
Die Zeitparameter ist immer sehr wichtig.
Zuerst werde ich die Zeitparameter messen
und im Blut werde ich Blutsettingung-Werte kontrollieren
mit Blutgasanalyse.
Ja, das wäre glaube ich ganz wichtig.
Ja, genau, Blutgasanalyse.
Und in diesem Fall brauchen wir Rotgärnaufnahme
und gegebenenfalls werde ich eine Computerautomografie veranlassen.
Sollte sich meine Diagnose bestätigen,
werde ich diesem Patienten ausgehört...
Dieser Patientin...
Dieser Patientin.
Patientin.
Ambulanz.
Ambulanzbehandeln.
Ambulanzbehandeln. Okay, was würden Sie empfehlen?
Ich empfehle dieser Patientin
viel Tehe oder Wasser trinken
und sich...
viele Vitamine...
Sie sollte sich mit vielen Vitaminen ernähren,
wie zum Beispiel Orangen und so weiter,
diese Früchte, mit dieser Früchte.
Und ich empfehle...
Ich werde Antigrippale Medikamente verschreiben.
Was sind Antigrippale Medikamente?
Antivirale Medikamente.
Antigrippale, ich meine nur symptomatische Behandlungen.
Also eine symptomatische Behandlung.
Also keine Antibiotik.
Sehr gut.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Das war sehr gut.
Sind von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch Fragen
oder Vorschläge, Verbesserungen, Kritik?
Am Anfang, welche Therapie können wir durchführen?
Sie hat ja gemeint, eine symptomatische Therapie
mit Schmerzmittel, mit Vitaminen.
Und damit meint man auch, wenn wir trinken.
Nasenspray zum Beispiel, Paracetamol, Ibuprofen.
Sie hat schon ja Nasenspray.
Erschuldigung, darf ich fragen?
Bitte schön.
Gibt es schnellstens im Praxis
oder man muss privat von der Apotheke?
Es gibt diese Schnelltests in der Apotheke, die kann man kaufen.
Und das muss man privat kaufen.
Viele Praxen haben das deswegen nicht in der Praxis.
Manchmal haben das die Krankenhäuser damit sich schnell diesen Test machen können.
Aber das wird normalerweise nicht von den Krankenkassen übernommen,
wenn man schnellstens so schnell ist.
Okay, weiter um Fragen.
Keine Frage, alles okay, alles richtig.
Sehr schön. Hören Sie mich?
Ja.
Wo ist die Frau Doktor?
Süleil.
Ja, ich konnte nicht hören.
Ich konnte sie nicht hören und ich sehe,
deswegen wollte ich fragen, wo sie sind.
Sie haben noch Fragen von anderen Kollegen?
Oder Vorschläge?
Ich unter?
Nein, von den anderen Kollegen, sie haben mir schon alles gesagt.
Ja, okay.
Sie müssen doch achten, jetzt geschlecht, Sie haben immer eher gesagt,
Frau Müller ist ja eine Sie.
Ja, ja, genau.
Deswegen müssen Sie eine Patientin sagen.
Aber das ist okay.
Sehr gut.
Das war schon mal sehr gut glaube ich, immer schon lang sein,
ruhig die Fragen stellen.
Und die Prüfung wird wahrscheinlich so ähnlich sein.
Und dann denke ich, dass es auch gut klappen wird.
Wir freuen uns auf eine positive Rückmeldung in zwei Wochen.
Okay, ich bin sehr erfrech.
Viel Erfolg, viel Spaß.
Vielen Dank.
Wir sehen uns vielleicht nächste Woche noch mal.